good afternoon everyone it's a nice
sunny Sunday afternoon so I decided to
get out of my house get out of the
apartment
come outside in the Sun to the party and
film my video here so today I want to
talk about one of the more popular or
talked about language programs or series
of language programs out there and it's
called Michelle Thomas I've used two of
the Michelle Thomas programs I've used
Michelle Thomas French and Michelle
Thomas Arabic which is Egyptian Arabic
by the way if you wanted to know and I'm
just going to give my review my
impression based on my experiences with
it now for each of them I did the basic
course the Advanced Course and the
vocabulary builder course I've done all
three for both of those languages the
names are not really accurate I don't
think any of the advanced ones are
really advanced I think it's more like
introductory part one introductory part
two and more introductory vocabulary
that's what I would rename them to I'll
get more into that later but basically
Michelle Thomas is an accelerated
learning program an accelerated learning
style his his big thing Michelle
Thomas's big thing is the an absence of
stress when you're learning there should
be no stress and no feeling of
responsibility for your own learning the
responsibility for your learning rests
with the teachers so you're supposed to
feel very relaxed when you're learning
and that puts you in a better state for
learning efficiently which is something
I agree with I try to use that in my
teaching as much as possible try to make
your students feel relaxed and feel that
there's no pressure upon them to learn
something they're not ready to learn all
of that so that's part of his
methodology is the lack of the absence
of stress and the absence of
responsibilities and when he's teaching
he's kind of meditative like you can
hear on the CDs when you listen to it
mr. Thomas himself he's he's very
relaxed and I think he's consciously
meditating and that's supposed to relax
the listener and the
so that's just something I noticed I
can't guarantee that but that's what I
feel when I listen to the guy himself is
meditating when he's teaching the course
that's supposed to transfer to you the
listener so there's that part another
thing another element of the accelerated
learning is that he teaches the language
in an order where everything that's
taught is connected to what's taught
next so everything is a building block
he's teaching you a small piece then he
teaches you another piece on top of that
and another piece and then you're
building progressively more difficult
sentences as he does that and the way he
does it is just very it's it's just very
easy to learn easy to learn each piece
and he does a good job of connecting
them and explaining them and using some
mnemonics to help you remember in that
kind of thing it's also a very teacher
centered approach so the teacher is
always directly engaged with you and
telling you what sentence to produce so
there's no free practice like basically
current methodology of language teaching
is you teach the language and then you
have some some exercises to practice the
language structures and after that
there's some kind of free practice like
somebody will ask you a question and you
have to respond freely from the things
you've learned without being prompted
without being reminded what to say
so at some stage you are producing the
language freely but in the Michelle
Thomas programs there's none of that
it's all controlled practice which means
that you're learning a lot of structures
kind of quickly but you're not given the
opportunity to produce them freely what
I think of it is the way he's set it up
is like a very sheltered environment for
learning that language you're not
supposed to do any homework you're not
supposed to use any other materials
you're only supposed to rely on him for
all of the learning so the positives of
this accelerated learning method are
that you feel very encouraged you feel
very encouraged and motivated because
it's set up in a way that you never feel
that you're failing you always feel like
you've succeeded
you're not allowed to fail in the method
really and if you make a mistake he
corrects you right on the spot and
you're supposed to fix it immediately so
you always finish every moment
of the lesson feeling successful so
that's kind of it's meant to encourage
you and meant to keep you in that ideal
learning state which is good for what it
is but it can be negative and in a way
part of the feeling of that that you
feeling constantly encouraged and
feeling it's nothing but success all the
time
it makes people sometimes feel kind of
invincible and it makes them delude
themselves into thinking that they're
really good at the language when
actually there's still a really low
beginner so that's kind of part of the
danger of the Michelle Thomas method you
can go online and you can read some
people's reviews of the method and you
look on Amazon some people are saying
wow I'm fluent after five hours and
things like that and you think no you're
not come on that's just a kind of self
delusion and I guess just people get
what's the word it's kind of euphoria I
would say from just that feeling of
success makes people really excited and
that's good if you are thinking of it
realistically if you know from the start
okay this is an introductory course I
don't expect to be fluent from this I
know that's impossible if you have that
realistic attitude in mind then that
sense of euphoria is good because it
motivates you to keep studying and to to
get some more materials and keep going
with it so it's good just don't fall
into that trap of thinking you know more
than you do because the danger of
learning in that really sheltered
environment where you feel nothing but
success nothing but relaxed kind of
confidence with the language when you
get outside of that into the real world
and you try to communicate with the
native speaker and you don't understand
anything and you can't remember how to
make a sentence you can't remember the
vocabulary you learned in that Michelle
Thomas sheltered box then you're going
to feel discouraged right if you're not
expecting that so that's that's like I
mentioned before you don't get any
experience interacting in the Michelle
Thomas program you don't learn how to
respond to anything that is said
unexpectedly you don't learn how to
accomplish a task you don't learn how to
paraphrase or say things you don't know
how to say yet it's always just you say
something you already know how to say
you say exactly what the teacher tells
you to
rolled for you to be able to transfer
that into conversations with native
speakers so it it's good for getting one
very basic thing down which is the
sentence structure of the language you
get the sentence structure and basic
vocabulary so you can make sentences but
the harder part of becoming proficient
in a language is interaction and
communication unless you just want to
type some sentences unless you just want
to write sentences and as an exercise
then you need to interact so that's the
part that's really the challenge and it
could cause a lot of discouragement if
you are not prepared for that just
focusing on the Michelle Thomas language
style of learning okay
so with all that said I think Michelle
Thomas is a great program and it's a
great learning system you just have to
remember that it's introductory once you
finish it you should you should
basically keep studying you need to well
I would make flashcards with the
vocabulary and the sentences that you
learned in Michelle Thomas and you can
find some of those online if you use
unki you can find some pre-made decks
that other people made and you can just
download them so I recommend those but
if not you can make your own flashcards
and review them so that you don't lose
that that language and also I would just
get into your next your next program of
study you get a textbook get some more
CDs that kind of thing start to take
lessons that's a big one start to take
real lessons with real people or get
some conversational tutoring through a
site like I talkie you know Skype
lessons that kind of thing just keep
going with your study when you learn
that much in a short period of time like
you do with Michelle Thomas that I think
you're in danger of losing it really
quickly too because the links are a
little bit loose he teaches with some
mnemonics and things like that that help
you remember but again the danger is if
you feel if you finish the program free
like I'm already good at this language I
can take a week off then you're going to
lose a lot of what you just learned in
those eight hours of Michelle Thomas
study so take it for what it is it's a
good beginners program once you're
finished keep it moving take that
motivation that you four
riah and use that fire to fight on and
get good at the language because you're
not good yet you just got a good start
so that's my impression that's what I
think of Michelle Thomas I hope that is
helpful talk to you later and have a
good sunny Sunday afternoon
ah